[موسيقى
] الشعاب المرجانية على طول ساحل مرسى علم
في مصر هي من بين الأفضل
في العالم حيث تضم أكثر من 300
نوع مختلف من الأسماك ، وهذا كنز دفين
للسباحين والغواصين ، إنه
لأمر مدهش حقًا أن هذا المكان بالنسبة لي هو واحد من
أكثر  مكان جميل زرته في أي وقت مضى على
هذه الشعاب المرجانية يظهر ضررًا بيئيًا أقل
من الشعاب المرجانية الأخرى في جميع أنحاء العالم ،
ويرجع الفضل في ذلك جزئيًا إلى جهود هذا
الرجل الذي كان بوسوم هيلمي رائدًا في
الحفاظ على الشعاب المرجانية لأكثر من 30 عامًا ،
حيث يدير ثلاثة منتجعات وحملات
بيئية لحماية بعض
الشعاب المرجانية الأكثر روعة في مصر
أهم شيء أعتقد أن
سيطرة الأشخاص الذين يستخدمون البحر إذا
تمكنت من القيام بذلك بالطريقة الصحيحة
ستنقذ الحياة البحرية في نفس اليوم من عام
1989 استقبل حسن مهمة بناء
أول منتجع له  وكان من المتوقع وجود غرفة كبيرة ،
لذا إذا وضعنا 1500 غرفة
في المنطقة هنا ، فلننسى أمر الحياة البحرية ،
مدركًا التأثيرات المحتملة على
البيئة ، فقد اختار بدلاً من ذلك بناء مبنى
أصغر بكثير  esort
لاستيعاب مائة وخمسة وسبعين شخصًا فقط ليس لدينا
الكثير من الغرف
والعديد من عيد ميلاد المستخدم للشعاب المرجانية في المنزل
لأن هذه هي القيمة التي نتمتع بها في
الحياة البحرية
داخل المنتجع ، حيث يتم تقييد استخدام البلاستيك للطاقة الشمسية
وإعادة تدويره والزائرين
شجعني على الانضمام إلى جولات التنظيف
اليومية للشواطئ المحلية بصفتي سائحًا ، فهذا
يجعلني أشعر بالرضا أنه يمنحني راحة
البال للاعتقاد بأنني أفعل شيئًا من
أجل البيئة لزيارة
قرية شقرا الرئيسية هو أن أكون مشاركًا نشطًا
في رؤية حسن
السياحة البيئية هي كنز لدينا
هنا لذلك علينا أن نقول أنه
بخلاف ذلك سنخسره